- What I do know about Hawaii.
That there was a queen.
You know, that's as far as it goes for me!
- I grew up in Hawaii.
I went to an all-Hawaiian school.
- I'm originally from Hawaii.
I went to a school that
only allowed Hawaiians.
- I grew up in Honolulu.
- I don't claim to know
anything about Hawaiian history.
- I don't remember learning
any Hawaiian history back in school.
Really, I don't.
Except Pearl Harbor.
- Being that I don't know anything,
I'm pretty sure I'm not gonna do the best.
- I'm kind of excited to see
how much I actually remember.
- Let's go take this test!
- [Lawrence] Who were the first people
to arrive in Hawaii?
- [Johanna] A, Polynesians, B, Tahitians,
C, Americans?
- I know someone from Fifth
Harmony that's Polynesian.
- What do you think?
- You asking me for what the answer is?
- Do you think you know it?
- Yeah, no, I definitely know.
- I think Polynesian?
- I guessed Polynesian.
- I said A, Polynesians.
- Polynesians?
- [Announcer] Polynesians is correct!
- Yay!
- Nice!
- [Announcer] It's Polynesians.
- Cool.
- [Shelden] Who was the
last king of Hawaii?
- A, David Kalakaua,
B, Kamehameha the Great,
C, Caesar Kaluaiku Kamaka'ehukai
Kahana Keola Kapa'akea,
and D, Steve.
- I mean, there's only
one that sounds right.
- I'm saying David Kalakaua.
- Nice, yeah, that's what I put down.
- A, David Kalakaua.
(bell ringing)
- Wow!
- Okay!
- Yay!
- [Kane] Hawaii's last king
was forced to sign away
the executive powers
of the monarchy.
Who took over power immediately after him?
- [Johanna] A, the people of Hawaii,
B, US Businessmen, C, the people of Kona,
D, The US Government.
- Oh God.
- I think it's the US Government.
- Who you going for?
- US Government.
- Yeah, that's what I put down.
- I put US Businessmen.
- US Businessmen?
- [Announcer] The answer
is US Businessmen.
- I mean it doesn't surprise me,
I feel like businessmen
have as much or more power
than the government in our country.
- They held the economy,
so, money talks, I guess.
- It makes me feel really sad.
I didn't even know that.
- [Shelden] In the 1890's,
Hawaii's last ruler,
Queen Lili'uokalani was
- [Lawrence] A, imprisoned,
B, forced to abdicate,
C, stripped of her power illegally,
D, all of the above.
- Forced to abdicate?
I'm just completely
guessing at this point.
- I'm going to say all
of the above, I think.
- I'm going to say all of the above.
- D.
- [Announcer] The answer
is all of the above.
- You guess all of the above?
- Yep. She was imprisoned
in her own palace.
- Like someone going into your
house and just being like,
you can't do anything here.
Go in your room and stay there.
- [Kane] After the overthrow
of the Hawaiian kingdom in 1893,
which of these were banned?
- [Alison] A, Speaking Hawaiian in school,
B, Consumption of Hawaiian dishes,
C, Planting of Hawaiian flowers,
D, All of the above.
- I mean, it's A.
- I definitely think it's A.
- I put A, speaking Hawaiian in school.
- Same.
- [Announcer] That's correct.
- My grandma, she didn't really get
to speak Hawaiian.
She didn't really know
about some of the Hawaiian
traditions and everything.
- In a culture where
history and information
is passed down through word of mouth,
by erasing the language,
you erase the memory.
- [Leimana] Which of these
is believed to be a reason
why hula dancing was banned?
- [Lawrence] A, Hula made Hawaiians
lazy and unwilling to work,
B, Hula threatened the
ability to convert people
to Christianity and was therefore evil,
C, it was a heathen practice
for physical pleasure,
D, all of the above.
- This is ridiculous,
I can't believe it was even banned.
- I feel like it's all of the above.
- I think it's Hula threatened the ability
to convert people to Christianity.
- I put the same one.
- [Announcer] It was all of the above.
- Damn it!
- I grew up dancing
hula, dancing Tahitian,
I can't imagine not having it in my life.
- [Shelden] After the
attack on Pearl Harbor,
how did the US use the Hawaiian Islands
to prepare for the war?
- [Alison] A, hiding missiles
within Hawaiian water supplies,
B, placing a specific tax on Hawaiians
to pay for weapons,
C, using one of the
islands as a bombing range,
D, putting underaged
Hawaiians into the army.
- This one's hard.
- No all of the above for this one,
which I feel like, wouldn't be crazy.
- I'm guessing it's either water supply,
or like, using an island
as a bombing range.
- I put B, C, and D.
- C, using an island as a bombing range?
- [Announcer] Yep, that's correct.
- You can't really get to the island
unless you go through
a certain organization,
because otherwise you might trigger
a bomb that hasn't exploded yet.
- This test is a hard test.
It's also exciting to get it right,
but then it's like, oh shit,
this is really sad.
- [Johanna] When did Hawaii officially
receive an apology from
the US government for its
role in starting the coup?
- [Leimana] A, 50 years after the coup,
B, immediately after their statehood,
C, after US military bases left,
D, 100 years after the coup.
- I don't know because I don't remember
there being an apology.
- Maybe 100 years.
I think it's D.
- Yeah, I think it's D as well.
- [Announcer] That's correct.
- 100 years!
- 1993, Bill Clinton
signed a formal apology
to our kingdom.
- They feel like it's okay to
just give them that credit,
then they can move on,
but give people their stuff back.
- [Leimana] On July 12, 1898,
the US formally annexed Hawaii.
However, international law dictates
that annexation treaties must by signed
by both countries involved.
This did not occur in Hawaii.
Given this information, is Hawaii a state?
- To be technical, Hawaii
is a illegal occupation.
- These are, like, you know,
laws that Hawaii never agreed to
in the first place as
far as being a state.
- I don't think it is a state,
just because of international law
that is still kind of
disputed to this day.
- You know, there are of
course, varying attitudes,
but, I mean, yeah, the fact of the matter
is the US took Hawaii
and called it a state.
It was a cool test.
I like that it highlights these issues,
but I feel like this was
an American history test
on the subject of Hawaii,
rather than a Hawaiian history test.
- I learned so much today,
I think how we view Hawaii in America
is just like a vacation paradise.
If we learned this in school,
we would be in a different frame of mind.
- Everyone should understand
what land they're visiting,
and where they're building things on.
- I knew a lot of the facts,
I'm going to a Hawaiian school,
but I didn't really know the full context.
This was really enlightening.
- It was really nice to
learn all this stuff,
and I definitely want to learn more
about Hawaii before the US,
and I wish that I'd sought
out this information earlier.